so this is actually the data center's
course for our size and excel so here in
our first class what we will be looking
at is we will understand what is
analytics and what are all the concepts
that we are going to cover in this
analytics session okay and we will also
see uh some of these statistical
concepts and how these statistical
concepts are related to business because
everything we are going to deal is only
with data so we will perform many
statistical operations and we will try
to see
how these statistical concepts are
related to business and what are all the
places it can be applied okay
and
we'll also see how to perform
the
statistical concepts in r and the
predictive model techniques in r and the
same thing will also be covering all
this parts in star studio and xlsb so
the basic analytic techniques and the
predictive modeling technique okay so
we'll start with analytics so
what is what is according to you what is
analytics so probably what we are
looking at is uh in this particular
world if you are looking at the
generation of
data is like very very huge and the
amount of data which is processed is
also like huge amount so everywhere if
you're looking at for an example if
you're looking at walmart they provide
they generate millions of data in
seconds so what we are going to do with
all this data so the data set is so huge
so what we are trying to do is we are
trying to derive some business insights
out of this entire data we are going to
crunch data and we are going to play
with data to get all business insight it
is not only about business insight it
can also provide you some research
insights it provides if there is a
particular problem analytics can give
you the solution
uh in terms of data so if we have a data
and you if you have a problem definitely
analytics could give you a solution for
it so that's what uh it is actually a
combination of
all data and business and statistical
part all these three things are clubbed
together to get some insight
so because only with data or business
you cannot do anything so you have to
derive some insight which is helping
your business so that's what we're going
to look in this particular course so
here if you're looking at for every
process uh every process that we're
going to do with
data science it deals with data so that
there should be some source where you're
collecting all your data so this is
where in data warehouse you'll be
collecting all your data and once you
collect all your data what you will do
is uh you'll you need to know what is
your data and what are all the
parameters which is available in your
data so you need to have a clear-cut
understanding of your complete data so
that's what you have to you'll be
applying all your statistical algorithms
or machine learning algorithms to know
what is your data and what what is it
telling because every data would have a
hidden story so as a data scientist what
you should do is you you try you should
try to derive the story behind the data
so that's what the main purpose of uh as
data scientists because
now i can tell every one of you as data
centers because you had entered into
this particular domain
where you should uh where you're going
to play with data and you're going to
get many insights that you want okay and
like developing advanced data driven
capabilities because
there are certain things which you could
uh
you should include with stats but
because business is also essential to do
some analysis because whenever you do a
process you should also know the
business value why you are doing this
process so without knowing the business
value it is it becomes tedious to do
this analytics so it is also essential
for us to learn the business value and
once you know the business value and the
statistical term collaborating both you
can provide multiple solutions which
help your business to move into the next
level and as a data scientist
if you're thinking that i am from a
program programming background does does
it help me to become a data scientist
if you have a question definitely it can
answer yeah because data scientist is a
combination of all the techniques like
you should have a programming knowledge
and you should have some business
knowledge and you should have some
statistical knowledge you should be a
good thinking uh you should have a good
thinking skills and you should have been
played with data so you should have some
exposure to db and some bi tools so it's
actually a data center is actually a
person who is skilled at all the
all the environment
so you cannot restrict yourself to only
particular technologies so you should
have awareness of all the technologies
and
once you go through this process it
becomes easy for you to understand like
what how other domains are working
so that becomes pretty much easier here
are some applications where analytics is
being a plane so if you're looking at
analytics i can bet you that wherever
you walk wherever you go you can apply
analytics there even if you're getting
into a bus or if if you're walking on
the road and if you're uh looking at the
signal everywhere analytics can be
applied so these are all the
applications where analytics is applied
so i'll just tell you uh some some of
the examples for all these sectors how
analytics is being applied okay so for
an example i work on retail sector for
the past four years
so generally if you're looking at retail
analytics application is very very vast
so for an example in making a promotion
or a replenishment or a demand
forecasting or a merchandising in all
these places uh
analytics is being applied for an
example just assume uh you're going to
work for walmart as a data scientist
there what you would do is that there
you you have to collect the data so
probably uh how you will start a
processes so whenever you get into a
retail store there you would see some
products which is
which is arranged in your shelf so if
you're looking at the arrangement of all
the products in the cell there are some
relationship between them for an example
if there is a kids section and nearby
you can find a woman's section because
like whenever you're going with your
family it is easy for women to take care
of their kids what they'll do is they
leave their kids in their kids section
and and if you're looking at kids
section everything will be
correlated together and if you're
getting into uh getting into a store
probably where you want to purchase a
brick there you would find an
association product like jam or butter
and you would find all these things
nearby and for an example if you're
getting getting into a liquor section
next nearby you will find some snacks or
side dish sections there so these are
all things which is associated together
so for doing all this process you need
the help of analytics so where to place
your product in what is the position
that you have to place your product
because every product would have some
relationship so whenever you get into a
store you should know what is the
relationship between the two products
their analytics can be applied and
money you had said
learning customer behavior and
consumption pattern yeah so learning
customer behavior customer behavior is a
problem which which fits into all the
domain because how we are going to
attract your customers so that is
actually a very very important thing
that you have to take in your business
so what are all the ways you can
attract your customers can someone tell
me like what are all the ways you can
attract your customer to your particular
store
or if you if we have uh say if you have
some customer base and if you want to
hold the same customer base no one
should
go out of this bond
so if i have 100 customers they should
stick with me they should not go to my
competitive store so for doing all these
things you need to know how they are
behaving and what they are interested in
so based on that you you can derive many
other patterns
and you have to suggest your customers
what is the decision that you have to
take and
what is the promotion that you have to
make for an example if i'm getting into
a retail store i can tell you thousand
problems that a retailer have how i'm
going to attract medical first problem
is like about the customer how i'm going
to get customer or how i'm going to
retain my customer so for doing all
these things i need to know what is my
interest what is my customer interest
for an example uh
if i hold a store
in a metro city and if i hold a same
store in a rural village okay so what is
the price that i should fix for my
product for an example if i hold an ice
cream shop near a airport and i'm
selling the ice cream for 500 people
would definitely get the ice cream
because they are like their economic
status is so high that they're
that they can afford an ice cream for
500 rupees and if i'm holding the same
shop in my rural village and if i'm off
uh the same example i'm from a rural
town
so if i'm starting a ibaco store there
there if i'm telling that a particular
ice cream is 400 do you think people
would get it definitely they will not
get because they think why should i pay
400 to get an ice cream so that depends
on people's mentality so how we are
going to understand your customers so
all these things analytics can help you
in understanding your customer so what
is their interest what is their
preference and all these sort of things
can be answered easily through retail
analytics okay so
and coming to replenishment so so
whenever you get into a store it is
mandatory for them to
keep their shelves filled for an example
if i am
holding a store in walmart what they did
is
they have different shelves for
different uh sections okay and if one of
the product is not there
then it is actually they can
they can just get a loss of sales
because i am just getting into a shop
where i am interested in getting a
butter okay and i am just getting at a
section and
to my luck
all the butter butter packets are being
sold out and my shelves is blank so
they're actually the company is
occurring a
loss of sales because i am interested in
getting a butter packet but
because it is not available in my shelf
i am not getting it that is also a loss
that the company gets so you should be
very cautious that every time your shelf
should be restocked it should be filled
with an appropriate stocking so there
are many problems with this talking and
under stocking and overstocking so we'll
also talk about that
and next is demand forecasting any idea
about demand forecasting why we are
doing a demand forecasting demand
forecasting is one thing which can be
applied in all these sectors all the
domains okay the stock products based on
potential consumption yeah so for an
example if i knew that this is the
particular quantity which is going to
sell in for this particular day then i
can hold an appropriate stock for an
example i am working in a manufacturing
company okay from from a place where it
is manufactured i am just moving it to
different stores
i am a manager of a particular store and
today i assume that only i am just
selling soaps in a particular section
and i assume that today only 100 soaps
will get sold
so that i am just holding only 100 soaps
in the particular shelf and in my
inventory i don't have any other soaps
so on on a particular day
unexpectedly there are almost 200 people
coming in and they're asking for so
and there i can i can meet the demand of
only hundred percent where the hundred
percent i cannot meet so there it is
actually a loss for me because if they
had more stock in my particular
inventory then i could i could have
solved all their problems because that
because i i had not predicted my future
demand well this problems occurred if i
am very sure that tomorrow the 1500
soaps would get sold definitely i can be
prepared for it if i'm not able to
predict my future values then it becomes
tedious for me to stock my inventory so
to hold my inventory so that's where
demand forecasting comes in so demand
forecasting is a problem which can be
solved by analytics which could tell you
what is what would be your future demand
for an example in the upcoming month
your sales can be 1500 or 2000 so i can
tell you with a numeric value what would
be your future demand so based on the
demand you can just plan it and you can
keep all the products in your inventory
so that's where the demand forecasting
is applied
and merchandising optimization so so
these are all different problems can be
solved in retail for an example if i'm
going to launch a product okay
where i should launch my product for an
example uh i i'm uh i'm a holder of
walmart store and i have almost 1000
stores in india okay and if i'm going
i'm going to launch a new product in
market
uh say i had it i'm just going to launch
a
new dress okay
which is a which is a fancy
authentic dress
so where i'm going to launch this
particular product in my hundred stores
because i have i have uh sorry thousand
stores i have thousand stores in india
okay where i'm going to launch this new
particular product i'm going to launch a
new product
no one had introduced that product in
market i am the first one to introduce
that particular product so i need to
know where i should launch this product
i have thousand stores in india in which
store should i launch this product so if
i knew that the top selling stores for
an example i find some store in delhi
and some stores in mumbai so that is
actually a metro city where my revenue
is more or where whatever products that
i get in is getting sold out easily so
those sort of stores i can believe then
i can introduce this product so that
that i can get a good exposure to market
i can reach out people very easily and
if they're interested then i can i can
extend my product to all other stuff
because if i introduce a product what if
it doesn't get sold
i cannot uh initially while launching a
product they will not launch almost like
a lakhs or two lakhs they cannot produce
and they cannot launch because uh if the
product is not liked by the customer
then definitely it is lost for me so
what i should do is it is actually a
test case that i am going to follow i am
going to take a product and i'm going to
launch in one of the few stores which is
performing well in those stores i can
put this product i can see how how
customers are reacting to my product
whether they are interested or not
interested there i can also take some
survey to the people and i can ask them
whether do you like my product or if you
don't like what are all the reasons why
you don't like
so after the test base i can just now
implement in all of the stores that is
one way
so this is one problem that analytics
can solve and in the same way if i ask
you a question like what are all the top
selling stores what are all the top
selling products or
what are all the locations which is
performing well or which is not
performing well all this basic ansys
analytics can
easily solve
and next coming to christine okay uh for
an example if i ask you a question
i am going to launch a new product and
say i am going to introduce a ice cream
so what is the price should i fix for my
particular ice cream so
how you would solve this particular
problem
these are all the problems which the
retail sector spaces so whenever you get
into retail it is not only with 10 to 15
products because if you're getting into
walmart there will be lacks and lacks of
products there for all the products the
same problem would have they'll be
confused uh what is the price that they
should fix or what is the quantity
that's it that they should
generate or they should manufacture and
what are all the locations they should
focus on and if i'm going to launch a
product
where i should launch it okay and money
you said promotion first yeah promotion
is one thing even if
promotion makes you like selling a
product very easy
so
how you would fix the price
so if i tell that promotion is the
second thing if you want to fix the
price what you will do is okay
competitive and brand price so first
thing is you would do is your cost price
so it should not be less than your
manufacturing cost so that should be in
your criteria okay yeah manufacturing
price and then you also look at your
competitive brand price because uh for
an example i have an ebaco store here
and nearby i have another store where uh
in the same way like i i'm just selling
the ice cream for 400 and if we selling
for 200 definitely people would go there
and it also depends on the quality
because if i is so good and there's so
quality they can offer they can also
provide the price so if you're looking
at one factor like price there are
multiple things which is related for an
example it depends on your manufacturing
cost and it depends on your competitive
price
you should not keep more price than your
competitor and you should also provide
equal quality that they provide and it
is also essential to introduce in a
proper market because if i'm introducing
the same ice cream in a local village
people will not get because their
economic status is very covered they
cannot offer this product so you should
be very clear that where you are going
to launch this product so these are all
different factors and all these factors
how you would derive how you would
analyze
so all these things comes from number
because number can tell you which store
is performing well and what is the
economic status of the people and how
much they are interested in your product
so keeping all this as your parameter
now you can decide your price that's
what uh analytics does because analytics
will tell you what is the pattern hidden
behind the data and it will give you a
suggestion what is the problem that is
that is prevailing in this particular
sector so based on the problem
accordingly you can uh take some
remedies to implement all these things
okay
so clear about it
and there are multiple applications even
after launching a new product for an
example i had worked on certain
analytics problem like product
association and price elasticity
analysis or demand forecasting there are
multiple problems for an example price
sensitivity analysis price sensitivity
analysis one such important thing
where
probably if i have 100 products in my
store
say for an example i am just planning to
raise a price of a price of some product
after increasing my price whether it is
going to affect my demand or not that is
called price and security analysis
because
for an example uh
if if there is a milk or petrol okay for
a milk and a petrol if i'm increasing
the price
will it affect my demand
do you think
if i increase the price of a petrol or a
diesel
does it
affect my demand it depends yeah it
depends and these are all things which
is mandatory so people even if you are
increasing to an extent people would not
mind because it is actually a need for
them without petrol or without food they
cannot survive so if i'm increase for an
example if i'm increasing
i have two
two shoes okay one sp one and one is
adidas okay so i'm increasing the price
of puma so people there is an
alternative for them to go to adidas and
get a shoe right because if there is an
alternative and then the price
increasing would cause a problem if
there is no alternative and that you can
definitely increase the price probably
it will not affect your demand so it
depends so where to raise your price of
a product and where it should decrease
your price of a product
so you all this answers can be
all these answers can be said by
analytics it can tell you these are all
some examples that i'm giving these are
all the application of analytics okay
okay matthew those who can differ
conceptional radius but essential
product consumption will be undefeated
yeah so essential product consumption
will not be affected to end to an extent
okay so to an extent it gets it will not
get affected but
uh for an example uh it is not necessary
for me to live with the shoe
so i i find that uh right now i'm just
planning to get a shoe and which is
my budget my budget is 2 000 and if it
exceeds more than 2000 it is not
mandatory for me to get that because it
is not my day-to-day need i can go for a
substitute product i take in or i can
reject my plan so in those sort of
project
price is very very essential so in terms
of retail there could be one lakh more
than lacks of product
where these companies would always have
a problem what is the price that i
should fix even after fixing should i
increase my price or decrease my price
with whether it is going to affect my
demand or not so all these questions
can be answered using analytics
and there are multiple applications and
one is like product association for an
example
if you're getting into stores there you
would find some offer products
say if i'm if you're getting milk butter
and jam all together is like 30 off so
why people generally how they are doing
it because if you are going to a store
people would provide you some combo
offers on what basis they are providing
you all this combo offer one product
would be selling the most and the other
product will not sell so
if you want to sell both the products
together then i can do some association
and i can club two things together
so because like whenever i go for a
retail store and if i'm getting a butter
or if i'm getting a bread then obviously
what i'll say is i i'm interested in
getting a milk or a butter and generally
butter will not sell as an individual
product it is actually associated with
bread so that i can introduce a combo
and i can sell both the things together
or if there are like
two things one is selling the high and
the other one is selling the low but
both the things have some association
then what i'll do is i'll try to combine
the two products and i can sell them in
market so that i can
tell both the products together
okay uh sometimes to encourage trying
new products yeah that is also one way
because sometimes if you want to launch
a new product to encourage the
particular brand you would do all this
sort of promotions
and all these promotions and what level
promotion you should take and all this
can be answered using analytics because
everything is from a number so
there are almost 100 200 problems that
can be solved using analytics in retail
so these are all general
problems that all the sector have okay
and next coming to health care
so any idea about health care where you
can apply analytics so much weight said
pricing for treatment and drugs yeah
definitely that is one thing because
some some of the drugs which is rare
which is available only at seasonal time
so those sort of drugs would cost in an
uh for an example for a cancer treatment
there is a flower in china
uh where the production is only in june
and may so those sort of time
their price would be less but for all
other times the price would be more and
uh
okay and rajesh you said symptoms okay
common symptoms to any illness yeah
that is also one great thing so
right now i am working on a project
which is
prenatal intensive care so prenatal
intensive care is nothing but uh
whenever a child is born if it is born
uh before the stipulated time
so it takes hardly 10 months to come out
come out to this world but what if a kid
is coming by seven months or eight
months so there the those kids uh will
not have
will not have that much uh health health
sufficiency to live so their uh
children's what we'll do is like we'll
keep an incubator and we'll have 24
hours survey so that people would keep
on monitoring the kit so they'll check
the heartbeat rate and they'll check the
blood circulation and all these things
are being captured so what as an
analysis what we do is generally i was
working on a central government project
which is actually a prenatal intensive
care
there will be recording the
the parameters of kid so what is the
weight that it holds and what is the
breathing rate and what is the
wbc rate and there are different
parameters we'll take take an account of
all these parameters and we'll try to
see
what is the problem that a particular
kit has and at what level uh the
particular symptom can become worse so
all these things you can predict easily
using analytics
so if you're thinking that you cannot be
a doctor then what you can do is you can
assist the doctor by telling all these
analysis because right now
if you're looking at
um
we had seen an image processing
technique where whenever a patient is
affected with cancer
the doctors would see a continuous
report every week they'll see how these
cancer cells are getting stimulated and
how it is getting extended so now uh
what they do is using analytics they
they make some automated way
based on this automated way they try to
find how these cancer cells are getting
populated and what is the threat of
their particular disease so these are
all the things you can diagnose and you
can just tell them easily and for an
example
there are certain cancer issues which
you can predict in an earlier stage so
if if some of your
some of your ancestors have the same
problem
how likely to uh for a person to get a
cancer or not so all these things can be
predicted easily uh using analytics okay
ganesh you said particular area people
what kind of basis they were affected
yeah good point so probably if you're
looking at the people
whoever is living in slums who who
cannot live in
uh in big places definitely they would
have some problems like uh
diarrhea and cholera these are all like
common diseases that they get because
you can also find easily after chennai
flood if i'm looking at there are many
some people who are affected with many
diseases so that definitely our
government can easily predict these are
all the possible diseases that can come
after flood so what are all the
locations where you you should
concentrate much and where you should
provide all the remedies first so all
these things can be answered easily so
these are all the common problems that
health care industry have
and
one thing is like drug interaction
so whenever you are looking at
cancer patient there are certain
medications they should follow and for
some people the medication
for their for their body condition that
would suit for some people it will not
it will cause in a negative reaction
so
using this analysis we can just track
them and we can find
uh what is the stage of their cancer and
what is the likely
date that they would live in or if it is
curable or incurable so all these sort
of things you can do with analysis so
everything deals with a number so
using all these patterns you can
easily identify the pattern you can
predict the future how it would be or
how you could stop this particular
disease okay so these are all the common
things
where in healthcare industries people
would do
and
coming to communication sector so first
is actually customer retention so
customer retention is a problem which
you can fit in all the sectors like say
retail or financial or
manufacturing or an energy sector
where in healthcare people would not
look in retailing customers because they
want their
patients to be cured
but
apart from there like you can see how to
retain the customer so if you're looking
at retaining customer how we are going
to retain a customer
say uh now there is a now there are like
competition uh between the giant
communication companies like uh atl or
or all these people if you're
looking at their first and foremost
point is how they are going to retain my
customer if i'm using vodafone
how likely i'm going to move to artel or
rsl that's what their first concern
would be because instead of acquiring a
new customer if you are able to make
your existing customer happy that is
more profitable to you accordingly so in
instead of getting 100 new customers if
i'm able to
retain my one lakh customer in my store
then that itself is a big thing for me
so every company would always look in
how how they can retain their customer
can someone tell me like what are all
the ways that people would follow to
retain their customer so if i'm holding
a store and i have one la customer so
what are the things uh if i do my
customers will stay in my same sector
matthew said future analysis to know
what which is to offer for each market
okay yeah so that you need to know what
is your customer so if you're looking at
the communication sector everyone would
provide different offers for me usually
i just talk
with all my clients and sometimes i i'll
be talking with
like people from different states there
they can provide me some good offers and
std calls and some people would be uh
making a call during night times so even
like there is there are like newer
offers newer sms offers and generally i
don't uh sms people so
so generally i don't get that particular
mail so if someone is like sending
continuous sms they will get offers in
terms of sms package so you are
targeting your particular customer and
they are sending some
some offers that they are interested in
so in order to send a particular offer
in order to focus a particular group you
need to know what is a group and how the
groups are reacting and what is the
interest of that particular group so all
these things can be answered using
analytics so analytics would tell you
okay these are all the groups that can
be formed and for this particular group
you can suggest this particular offer
so some people uh
for me like this is actually a patent
that i follow so every friday or
saturday i'll be going to a liquor shop
i'll be getting something and i'll come
out so if you're looking at
some of the offers that i get i i i see
all my offices related to liquor so i
can be bad but not that bad okay so only
on friday or saturday i'll have so i i
get some specialized
sms that which which fits me so which is
my interest and if you're looking at uh
my sister or what she'll be getting
she'll be getting some
offers through flipkart or amazon so
even that that would that is actually
like they're trying to learn your
behavior an example a simple example is
whenever you go to a flick or amazon
site just go to a product and three four
two three times for example i was
planning for uh
getting a skullcandy headset i was
looking for the price for two three days
and obviously whatever web web pages
that i browse i can see only skullcandy
ads there from flipkart or amazon how
they are doing it because they are
actually tracking your
way that you are searching and they
found what is your interest more than
you google know who you are
so people are easily getting your data
and they are just trying to find your
interest for an example if i'm looking
at polar color book for five to six
times then obviously i'll get
advertisement or individual individual
advertisement
regarding books that they can they can
this provide
two polycolor books would cost almost
5000 or 6000 they can provide all those
plants and they can target you so in
order to know this you need to know what
is customer and what is their interest
so and if you're looking at some ola or
cab facilities what they'll do is
they'll provide some offers on a
particular day to retain their customer
so these are all the things you're gonna
directly take in promotion you need to
know what is the promotion that you're
going to do for a particular customer so
you need to understand
who is your customer and what is the
behavior of your customer so all these
things come from analytics
and
monika you said providing best services
like good call plans yeah that is that
is actually one thing because they know
what is the call plan that you are
interested in they are trying to
understand uh the way that you make
calls so based on that they provide you
offers so
to make an offer you need to understand
your customer who who is your customer
how he is behaving exactly so all this
behavior can be easily tracked nowadays
it is very easy to track
one
interesting thing that i was working on
is i was working on a uk project uk
company
so there in that particular retail store
what they'll do is
whatever customers whoever customer that
they're getting into their store they'll
provide free wi-fi and they'll just
collect their numbers so if they want to
get a free wi-fi connection in that
particular store they have to provide
their mobile number so once it is
registered whenever they get into the
store they can use their uh wi-fi for
easy okay
there is a free wi-fi there
so after introducing this particular
scheme what they try to do is whenever
the customers are passing uh near to
their streets an example i uh when we
are working on a uk project what that
particular company do is if a particular
customer who had already come to the
store he is trying to get into another
store or he is moving in an area which
is nearby for example i hold a store in
a particular
location
and within 100 meter radius if if my
customers are entering definitely uh
instantly the company what they'll do is
they'll send an sms today there is a
offer there is a 30 offer on speeds so
if you're interested just get into the
next lane and come to a store so these
are all like nowadays the marketing had
been very very improved so even if
you're crossing a store you will get a
sms so here this is offer we are
providing if you're interested get this
product
so people are targeting individual
customers initially they were targeting
group of customers now it had become a
scenario where
the companies are focusing each and
every customer because each and every
customer is important to them how they
are going to retain them
with all this uh plans
because then definitely people sometimes
would fool you even we suggest whenever
i get into a store i would think okay i
should not get uh
get any combo offers which is beyond my
limit but definitely on looking at the
store or on looking at the combo
packages that they provide
people are easily attracted to it and
they are
getting the product so this is how they
are retaining their customer and how
they are increasing their marketplace
and one one example i can tell but
definitely no one would believe that
does a
product cover
would cause an impact on sales much we
said yes so i had seen through my eyes
so there were like two companies okay
they're providing uh i don't want to
tell their name
they're actually like a competitor
companies two different companies and if
you're looking at the products quality
both both of the people provide with
same product with same quality same
amount of quality
but the opposite company they are not
able to figure because one company
is so very very good in market but in
that in that particular company only one
product is not selling that great but
the competitor company is selling the
same product in a higher profit and they
they are like people are still
interested in getting more and more
products there we are not able to figure
out why uh because these two companies
they were looking at okay my product
quality is also good this is also good
and i am also fixing the same price that
what he quotes even i had tried to
reduce but even then i cannot meet his
sales so in that case what we found is
one simple thing is we are not able to
see from our past data so we don't know
because uh even we are selling the same
product in the same location even then
we are not able to figure out what is
the problem then we just took a survey
okay what is a uh thing that you love
about this product and you know about
the second product there we found most
of the people they were suggesting that
the package that the company provides is
good looking so they provide a zip
package so whenever you that is actually
a product where you can put all the
things in a zipped packet so that is
only one thing which attracted the
customer so because of that there is a
difference of almost 480 crores so do
you think that only one cover would cost
480 crores
initially we thought okay why this color
would cause an impact or not we thought
that but when you're looking at the
profit margin that difference is
actually 480 crores then we suggest
suggested them just provide a zip lock
package
and we thought which color to provide so
we initially
because which color to provide i don't
have any data so what we did is
we just took a six month survey to all
the customers getting into the store and
we were asking
for this particular product what is the
most preferable color that you would
suggest so everyone said
most of the ladies they suggested if it
is a pink
reddish pink
that will be looking good so after
increasing the color occurring after
changing the color and after making a
small change in package
now we've we saw the product sales was
like increased by 480 or 460 crores
so these are all small things but when
coming into our largest so say for
walmart
if they're making this alteration and
they're selling in almost uh two lakh
stores just think how much profit they
would get in so it is very essential to
know all these things
so you may think that color or a package
would be a smaller
thing according to us but when getting
into overall scale
it speaks differently so the profit that
you get is also completely different
so all these things how you would know
all these things comes only from data
because walmart cannot go and see how
each uh for example if i'm holding a
petty shop i know okay secret is selling
well and uh beetle nuts is selling will
or if i'm holding only 10 products in my
store
or
if i'm holding a
shop where i hold shoes and uh clothes i
know which clothes is selling the best
but what if i have thousand stores
across india and i have more than two
lap products then it becomes tedious
right so there you need to know how each
and every product is behaving and what
is the action to take for each and every
product that's where the help of
analytic comes in
so these are all examples and coming to
capacity planning so what is the
uh people say is that how many networks
i should build there and network
optimization so all these problems can
be solved using analytics
you